[Musique]
oui
je me sens fatigué et et du haut de ma
timidité que vous avez pu observer
j'ai décidé d'avoir une approche qui
allait changer un peu les choses surtout
que mes piqueurs et est si talentueux
qui oubliait tout mais ce pitch et je ne
pouvais que danser alors la paire 6 la
percée pour moi c'est une transformation
audacieuse avec un impact positif
est ce que mon père me disait
tout a commencé le 24 août 2013
à 12h15
laurent souvient
quand mon père est décédé
et à ce moment là ton monde s'effondrer
tout partait j'étais bancaire d'affaires
à londres
c'est à peu près 15 ans que je les paie
et je me souviens je l'avais dit je
voulais rentrer en côte d'ivoire et
devenir banquière travaillait à la
banque et il me disait tu peux être co
fondé de pouvoir lui parle tellement que
si tu fais autre chose à a pas marché
à moins qu'ils travaillent pour toi même
donc ce 24 août à 12h15 après avoir
remémoré et répété dans mon esprit ce
qu'était la percée je me suis dit il
fallait que la mémoire de mon père vit
en moi à travers ses valeurs et ses
principes
ainsi débuta ma transformation postale
et abidjan
j'ai regardé un peu les services et j'ai
réalisé que j'avais été j'avais reçu un
service client qui était pas très adapté
à ce que je souhaitais dans une banque
de la place
je suis reparti à londres avec une amie
à moi et on a décidé de créer un cabinet
qui travailleraient ou qui opérerait
totalement sur le service client
alors sans fliers en rien avec juste
cette idée comme suit mon jeu va les
vendre à des entreprises au service
client tout le monde en a besoin
j'arrive je vends je me fais chasse et
de bureaux je me fais traiter d'
illusionniste
j'ai même certains clients qui me dise
où certains prospects à l'époque indies
mais à quoi tu peins ce service client
mais c'est quoi ce nouveau mou nous on
travaille on a besoin de faire notre
profil de quoi tu parles
et avec mon amie avec laquelle j'ai
décidé de créer on est toujours à la
recherche en fait de ce vraiment d'effet
de percer là et six mois après je me
rends compte qu'on n'a plus les mêmes
objectifs
elle est mariée à quelqu'un de très
fortunés mois par
et je me rends compte que nos objectifs
sont différents et on se sépare donc je
me retrouve tout seul mais passeur et je
me dis mais en fait la vraie
problématique c'était dans la conception
de ce que je vendais devant un service
client je vais essayer de parler aux
gens qui travaillent en entreprise et
essayer de voir ce dont ils ont besoin
et je commence à discuter avec les
personnes en entreprise et je me rend
compte qu'elles sont pas valorisées
elles se sentent mal aimés
elle se sent peu récompensés elles ont
l'impression qu'on ne les voient pas
leurs volets émotionnel n'est pas prise
en compte
on ne voit pas leur talent et on gère
mal lors des différents conflits les
conflits pardon en entreprise
elles ont du mal à s'exprimer en public
voisine en fait linda tu t'es trompé
doit pas vendre le service client mais
tu dois plutôt vendre la productivité
d'une entreprise à travers des hommes
parce que voilà la valeur ajoutée d'une
entreprise où on revient
je commence à vendre mais à ce moment là
je parle en entreprise en leur disant
écoutez vous permet d'avoir une
rentabilité x 100 si vous mettez l'homme
au coeur de vos activités
votre staff n'arrive pas à vous donner
est le potentiel parce que vous ne savez
même pas qui il est vous n'arrivez pas à
le comprendre vous n'arrivez pas à
discuter avec lui et vous ne le
retrouvais pas n'arrivait pas à gérer
les conflits vous savez pas qui il est
et à ce moment là ça commence à résonner
dans les esprits et tout le monde me dit
ah mais finalement si ce volet
émotionnel on ne le connaissait pas
vraiment et on le pratiquait pas
et je leur explique le nom de mon
antique où apple kaisen le cai et le
scène une connotation japonaise pour
ceux qui connaissent il part sur tout ce
qui est amélioration continue et je leur
dis mais c'est vraiment le volet
émotionnelles il faut remettre en cause
c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut vraiment
mettre au coeur de vos différentes
activités
ça vous permettra d'être un peu plus
productifs penser à l'homme le capital
humain a une importance énorme pas
seulement la productivité parce que vous
ne voyez que sur vos bilans
les chiffres ont dit que les chiffres
sont faits par des personnes penser à
celle ci et vos chiffres vous remontez
et à ce moment là que certaines
entreprises commencent à discuter avec
moi et les mêmes entreprises qui vont
chasser à l'époque m'ont mise dehors ont
traité de fans ont commencé à m'appeler
j'ai eu à faire des formations gratuites
il faut alors faire connaître un peu
cette méthode qui était très méconnu et
j'ai eu à remettre enfin l'homme la
valeur humaine le capital humain le
potentiel que nous avons sur la table
j'ai eu à nous remettre au devant des
choses parce que nous sommes réellement
les vrais conducteurs de ces entreprises
ces entreprises ont du mal à le
comprendre c'était le plus important
pour moi de leur faire comprendre cela
et c'est comme ça que mon aventure a
débuté et que kaizen a commencé à voir
des clients perdent vous payez pas
mais quand même des clients on pouvait
progresser et on apprenait et ont montré
à tout le monde cette valeur et je me
suis rendu compte que progressivement la
performance montait mais j'étais pas
satisfaite parce que je me disais à
l'école j'ai pas reçu être cette
formation est celle là où ça commence
celle à la base et j'ai commencé à faire
ces formations dans les écoles
je me suis approché de certains lycées
et j'ai commencé à former des petites
filles en classe de seconde et je leur
ai dit ce qui était important
on se rend compte que dans nos pays
ravagé par des guerres malheureusement
la valeur de la jeune fille la valeur de
la femme a complètement baissé et ses
jeunes fils à ne savent plus ce qu'ils
recherchent
elles n'ont plus de modèles elles savent
pas du tout pourquoi compter et je me
suis rendu compte qu'à leur âge j'avais
cet homme était mon père qui me guidait
et pour certaines elles ne l'ont pas
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'argent a pris le
dessus
donc il fallait leur inculquer un amour
propre
une estime de soi mais surtout une
capacité à changer leur environnement de
la manière positive et à penser qu'elle
valait la peine d'en avoir à faire comme
on le disait tout à l'heure de la
prostitution ou sans avoir à vendre de
leur personne pour aller de l'avant et
ça c'était mon plus beau cadeau
parce que quand je discutais avec ces
jeunes filles je me rendais compte
qu'elle en avait énormément et que leurs
compétences et leur savoir-faire été mal
utilisé et ça me fait plaisir de voir
qu'aujourd'hui certaines de ces jeunes
fils en fera nous grandir ont des femmes
à impact fort mais surtout avec un
objectif clair qui est de continuer à
influencer de la meilleure
hier et respect avec leurs valeurs
africaines où leur sont propres à ce
moment là j'ai eu l'impression que ma
tâche était quasiment atteinte
mais quelle est la différence nous
faisons toutes ces actions de forme de
forme mais comme on le disait tout à
l'heure l'innovation est la clé du
développement ont réellement être cette
percée il faut pouvoir nourrir ses
innovations
malgré les échecs que j'ai eu à
rencontrer pensait toujours à winston
churchill qui disait la réussite en
elle-même n'est pas réellement la
réussite en elle-même c'est la
succession de ses échecs mais avec un
enthousiasme et enthousiasme de moi que
vous avez vues estime et le même
enthousiasme que j'avais même quand on
était mon père son père parce que
j'avais froid que ce moment très
difficile était un moment pour moi de
permettre à saleh à sa son héritage de
continuer à vivre mais c'était surtout
le moment pour moi de partager toutes
les valeurs fortes m'avait apprises et
c'est pour cela que j'ai décidé de me
lancer dans ce dans quoi je m'étais
lancé
mais il faut surtout nourrir cette
percée que j'avais découvert et pour
nourrir cette percée au delà de
l'innovation
il nous faut penser aussi à travailler
sur nous mêmes nous avons une capacité à
ne pas vouloir travailler
nous pensons que tout nous est dû de là
où nous sommes tout nous est dû et nous
n'avons pas besoin de nous battre pour y
arriver mais c'est souvent il faut
travailler mais il faut surtout se dire
qu'on est au premier plan
quelqu'un le disais tout à l'heure que
c'est à travers nous que les autres
vivent en effet oui c'est vrai on a
tellement tendance à reléguer tout au
second plan en ce qui nous concerne on
ne le fait plus bien pour bien faire il
faut se mettre au premier plan
parce que ce qui est bon pour vous sera
forcément bon pour l'autre
et quand vous faites quelque chose et
que vous le faites avec un désir de vous
faire plaisir
automatiquement vous créer quelque chose
qui va faire plaisir à l'autre est ce
que je veux dire par le travail sur soi
après le travail sur soi tout le monde
le dit il faut se battre il faut pas se
battre contre son environnement je me
bats pas contre mon environnement et
vous devez pas vous battre contre votre
environnement vous devez vous battre
contre vous même parce que votre
environnement à capacité à être sain et
à vous donner ce plus de boost qui vous
permet d'améliorer vos compétences de
devenir encore plus fort vous êtes vous
même votre propre ligne et
personnellement je n'ai jamais voulu
être ma limite je me dis toujours que le
ciel n'est pas mme halimi parce que je
en tant que chrétienne via le paradis
aux mêmes le ciel n'est pas une limite
et cette bataille pour la faire contre
soi même parce que c'est toujours cette
petite voix négatives qui nous dit mais
non tu peux pas y arriver
mais de quoi est ce que tu parles ils
devaient écouter cette petite voix je
serai jamais devant vous parce que je
serais resté la banquière d'affaires
aurait fait des fusions des acquisitions
avec grand plaisir et un salaire assez
confortable selon moi mais c'est cette
bataille personnelle que j'ai eu affaire
m'a permis d'avoir la force de vouloir
créer les leaders africains de demain
parce que nous avons des talents et nos
talons sont enfouis en nous et propos de
personnes parlent de nos talents
africains
on parle trop souvent des talents
européens et occidentaux et on oublie
que nous somme de talents
nous sommes un géant l'afrique énorme et
regorge de talents
nous devons pouvoir être transporté par
cette idée talentueuse et cette bataille
là c'est nous mêmes qui devront le faire
après cela il faut avoir du courage
enfin beaucoup de courage parce qu'on va
se faire complètement humiliée parfois
traité de fou on va même avoir des
commentaires négatifs de notre
environnement proche de nos familles
ça peut arriver de nos époux auront
l'impression que notre indépendance
dérange et qui va nécessairement créer
les divorces regardé par là mais il faut
surtout se dire ce courage on l'a dans
mon le disais on est tous différents
mais on l'a on a réellement et c'est
seulement en face de situations
conflictuelles situation difficile on
réalise qu'on a ce courage après ce
courage comme michael tas de le disais
nous sommes les propres producteurs et
l'arist acteurs
tout ce que vous pouvez entendre je suis
là propre productrice de mon fils je
suis une actrice principale de mon film
je suis la danseuse principale de mon
film et que ceux qui a envie de regarder
mon film dans leur garde ceux qui n'ont
pas envie de regarder mon film ne le
critique est pas c'est ça la différence
et il faut avoir un niveau de
crédibilité
pas facile et pouvoir tenir la parole en
tant qu'entrepreneur ce n'est pas facile
n'était pas la chose la plus aisée parce
qu'on vit dans une société qui nous crée
beaucoup de dominos effet financièrement
et émotionnellement parlant
et c'est là la grande difficulté parce
qu'il faut pouvoir respecter ses
engagements malgré les difficultés qu'on
rencontre
je vous avoue que parfois j'ai du mal à
respecter les miens et je suis très mal
parce que je ne sais pas comment régler
cela et en face de moi j'ai des
personnes qui me verront bien mise parce
que j'aime être bien mieux quand même
ivoirienne et à travers cela ils vont se
dire mais on va bien elle n'a pas de
problème messi
et quand tu vas dire non je n'arrive pas
à régler x parce que j'ai un petit
soucis permets moi d'avoir y de temps on
aura l'impression que tu prends les
autres peut-être ont des petits jeux et
que tu n'y penses pas mais cette parole
et les respecter simplement quand vous
avouez vous êtes incapable de respecter
quelque chose au moment t et que vous
avez l'intention de le respecter et que
vous avez un moment de relâche et que
c'est impossible pour l'instant la
communication vous permet encore une
fois d'avoir ce niveau d'intégrité et de
respecter cette parole parce que vous
respectez la personne en face de vous
des rayonnements ça le plus important
après cela ou vivre avec passion pour
vendre ce qu'on vend avec passion je
vends mes formations avec toute ma
passion est une vocation pour moi de
pouvoir travailler avec une jeune fille
et de lui dire voilà comment tu prends
la parole
voilà comment tu tiens tes jambes voilà
comment tu regardes au mur pouvoir avoir
un accent fort
voilà comment tu impact dans
l'environnement le transporte tout le
monde avec moi parce qu'en fait cette
passion de la vie elle est en moi et mes
enfants fruits vous la sentez même à
l'instant pris la santé et seconde il
allait aussi il faut continuer à le
partager
parce que c'est en le partageant que
réellement ont fait sortir notre talent
notre potentiel et ensuite notre désir
d'impacter fortement mais fortement avec
la plus grosse force nausée
de ce fait linda affine quoi si je suis
la directrice générale du cabinet kaizen
et nous sommes en angleterre et abidjan
on désire fort et de créer les africains
leaders de demain
mais surtout les femmes africaines
fortes auront un désir plus fort
delà des soucis qu'elle pourra
rencontrer au quotidien aura un désir
plus fort de parler d'autonomisation
mais qui se diront en fait je suis
autonome je n'ai pas de limites et mon
désir le plus grand c'est vraiment
d'impact et mon environnement au
quotidien au quotidien au quotidien je
vis je dors j'oserais dire cela
parallèlement la persévérance et la
détermination sont nos valeurs
d'épisodes une peau tente vraiment ce
qui me définit et c'est ce qui me permet
d'être en face de vous aujourd'hui la
détermination et la persévérance
parce qu'après tout les échecs que j'ai
connu après la grosse perte que j'ai
connu ma foi m'a permis d'être là
aujourd'hui
et comme tout à l'heure par nous parler
du saint-esprit va oui
lui qui nous accompagnent mais par
dessus tout cette persévérance m'a
permis de vendre cette idée que j'avais
de la mettre sur papier auquel
deviennent aujourd'hui père si vous avez
en face de vous mon désir le plus ardent
c'est de vous laisser avec le même désir
que j'ai est d'être la meilleure fille
pour ma mère la meilleure mère pour ma
fille de 12 ans la meilleure servante
pour mon environnement à qui je
permettrai de grandir et de faire sortir
son potentiel pour impacter notre belle
afrique
et surtout
surtout la personne la plus humble vous
dit
[Musique]